il ya sept ans je me suis joint à une
bande d'amis pour aller sur des
bidonvilles construire des toilettes
sèches
je n'avais jamais mis les pieds sur un
bidonville et j'y suis allé animé par
une certaine curiosité mais également
pour rencontrer un politologue vrai sur
place et qui m'intriguait quelques
semaines après tous ces efforts et les
nôtres comme bien souvent se sont
trouvés rasée par une pelleteuse à la
suite de ça j'ai vu passer comme à
chaque fois les titres de presse qui
nous annonçait que un bidonville
insalubre avait été rasée et que
l'ensemble des familles avaient été
relogées par le préfet mais cette fois
ci j'ai vu passer les images de ces
fameuses hôtel j'ai vu passer le coût
faramineux de ses hôtels ses nuits kit
est vendu à l'état à nous en sommes et
là j'étais révoltée j'étais révoltée
contre moi même d'avoir cru sans
sourciller ses titres de presse il s'est
produit à ce moment là un basculement
dans mon travail et j'ai choisi de
transformer ma pratique et de mettre mes
compétences au service de ceux et celles
qu'on ne regarde pas assez
et tant qu'à faire dans des situations
où il est question de dépenses publiques
alors j'ai saisi l'occasion d'un appel à
projet un projet social innovants portés
par la mairie de saint-etienne et la
cité du design un appel d'offres sur la
réhabilitation d'une bibliothèque dans
une école publique en zone d'éducation
prioritaire
un marché qui était à la fois de la
conception et aussi de la concertation
quand je suis arrivé sur place j'ai
utilisé la métaphore du médecin
généraliste pour expliquer aux enfants
mon rôle de designers architectes
en effet le médecin pour pouvoir soigner
a besoin de poser un bon diagnostic et
pour peser un bon diagnostic
il lui faut ausculter le patient
constaté des symptômes mais également le
questionner ce patient car lui seul peut
savoir où il a mal depuis quand et
comment si le patient ne sait pas
comment se guérir le médecin lui doit
savoir lui poser ces questions pour
réussir à le soigner
c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait sur ce
projet j'ai ausculter le bâtiment c'est
à dire que j'ai analysé
globalement tous les dysfonctionnements
j'ai questionné les usagers sur leur
environnement et peu un peu je les ai
aidé à développer un regard critique sur
le lieu dans lequel il vivait cette
bibliothèque
comme bien d'autres dans bien d'autres
écoles servette a beaucoup d'autres
choses elle était aussi un espace
d'archives/reuters de repos de salles de
déjeuner et également de salle de
reprographie il faut imaginer l'ambiance
quand il est 14h et que ces petits
garçons et petites filles arrivent tout
juste devant la bibliothèque
ça sent encore le chou farci et la
sardine on leur demande d'être assis sur
un banc raid entre le photocopieur qui
débite des centaines de support de court
et un massicot
là il faut trouver le plaisir de lire
pour les enseignants ne s'était pas non
plus l'idéal puisque cette bibliothèque
était au deuxième étage
et lorsque la khl la cloche sonnait il
descendait les enfants dans la cour de
récréation remontait au deuxième et à
chercher leur tasse traversait tout le
couloir pour aller au point de chercher
un petit peu d'eau retraversait pour
aller faire chauffer leurs tasses
prendre un peu de cas fait descendre à
nouveau les deux étages pour traverser
la salle de classe qui permet d'accéder
ensuite un petit jardin et là il peut
fumer leur cigarette à l'abri du regard
des enfants
l'humain s'habituant à tous il faut
l'arrivée d'un oeil neuf pour se dire
que non sur ce projet la question ne pas
de répondre à des mobiles avec du
mobilier modulable qui permettra la
cohabitation de toutes ses activités
dans un seul et même espace
il faut s'autoriser à dézoomer et à
remettre en question la commande pour
pouvoir
globalement apporter une réponse plus
satisfaisante et remettre au coeur des
travaux
l'objectif pédagogique à savoir donné
l'envi de lire à ses enfants
mon travail a été d'accompagner la main
tous les acteurs à la fois la ville mais
à la fois les usagers nous avons déplacé
la bibliothèque au rez de chaussée
pourquoi ainsi profiter de l'accès
direct sur le petit jardin et les trois
locaux contigus qui était vacant pour
délocaliser la cantine la cuisine et
l'espace de reprographie des ateliers
pédagogiques
il était ressorti que les enfants
souhaitaient que cet espace sauter un
espace calme jusque là tout allait bien
mais au-delà de ça il avait décidé de
l'ambiance générale et s'étaient
accordés sur le fait qu'ils avaient
envie d'être comme allongés au milieu
d'une grande vague turquoise
je vous cache pas mon désarroi ce soir
là quand je suis rentré chez moi je
n'imaginais pas du tout le monde
aquatique avec le monde littéraire
à ce moment là j'ai bien saisi quel
était mon rôle à moi de designers je
devais être la traductrice de leur
intention et réussir à donner forme à ce
qu'ils ne sont pas capables de nommer
ensuite il ya je voudrais aborder un
point qui est très important pour moi
parce que si justement j'ai été comme ça
très désarçonné par leur demande
j'ai joué le jeu pour moi l'honnêteté de
la collaboration est très importante
certes je ne savais pas comment m'y
prendre mais je devais respecter leur
parole
il est important de ne pas faire croire
aux usagers des concertations
ce sont leurs réponses que l'on va
appliquer mais il ne faut pas non plus
leur demander leur avis sans savoir en
tenir compte
alors la vague une fois traduites ça
donne ça une estrade qui dévale dans la
pente qui permet plusieurs la modularité
des positions une grande ligne d'horizon
qui structurent l'espace et les signes
typographiques
ils font le lien et nous permettre de
dessiner des mouettes et les vagues
ce travail nous avons réussi à le faire
parce que l'équipe était dans un cadre
de confiance et sept sont des personnes
en gage
dans une quête de bon sens et nous avons
également réussi à le faire grâce à
l'investissement financier de la mairie
parce que ce déplacement de la
bibliothèque au rez de chaussée à
augmenter la surface de la bibliothèque
est donc le budget travaux et forcément
c'est toujours là vous ça pique un peu
mais mon rôle qui m'a permis de les
accompagner au quotidien et la réponse
qui était bien plus complète que le
problème initial les a convaincus et la
ville a suivi cet investissement
financier c'est la clé de voûte d'un tel
projet parce qu'il donne de la valeur au
travail collaboratif il reconnaît la
parole des enseignants et il rend les
enfants extrêmement fier forte de ces
constats
j'ai eu envie de les amener dans une
autre échelle
si j'avais réussi à convaincre une
petite communauté d'usagers qu'il
pouvait prendre la main sur leur
environnement et pouvait le changer je
voulais aller outils et des porteurs de
projet encore plus ambitieux alors j'ai
rejoint le politologue qui m'avait tant
fasciné sur les bidonvilles et on est
parti à avignon je me suis installé pour
huit mois à côté de la gare centre dans
un groupement d'alger co qui se pose est
là au milieu d'une cour la cour d'un
bâtiment
le bâtiment du tri postal de la ville ce
bâtiment était désaffecté depuis une
vingtaine d'années c'était trois mille
mètres carrés et il appartenait à un
réseau ferré de france dans ce bas
denses et alger qu un vrai au quotidien
une association qui accueillait des
personnes sans abri pour leur offrir du
temps et un toit pour pouvoir se retaper
un toit oui mais un toit extrêmement
précaires celui d'un algeco l' envie de
partir dans un bâtiment plus grand
un vrai bâtiment bâtiment solide et est
là mais les projets n'aboutissent jamais
je me suis retrouvé aux côtés de cette
association parce que son nouveau
directeur général avait décidé de ne
plus choisir cette option là de ne plus
chercher à partir mais bien de passer à
l'abordage du bâtiment tri postal vim
trois mille mètres carrés on n'allait
pas faire 3000 mètres carrés de pauvres
ça n'aurait eu aucun sens mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut inventer
c'est sûr il faut aller au delà de cette
question de l'amélioration physique des
espaces d'accueil
nous avons proposé d'élaborer
conjointement un programme de
réhabilitation de ce bâtiment à partir
des problèmes rencontrés au quotidien
mais alors que proposait qu'elle mixité
comment vivre avec ces personnes qui
désirent cette ville qui désirent cette
mixité mais qui sont qui en sont exclus
depuis tant d'années à quel moment pour
y faire quoi
quelle activité comment faire ensemble
et bien toutes ces questions il faut les
vivre selon moi pour réussir à y trouver
des réponses qui soit au delà des
stéréotypes et des bons sentiments que
l'on peut appliquer au loin dans un
bureau la force de ce genre de démarche
la force de ce travail c'est que l'on
construit un projet stratégique à partir
d'expérimentations concrètes et on
valide pas à pas les usages et les
activités
c'est quelque chose que je vais vous
raconter notamment sur un point en
particulier une idée que nous avions eus
qui était celle d'une cantine solidaire
dans les algeco vous les 10 12 personnes
arrivées chaque soir pour dormir
si la nuit il était occupé le jour il
était vide cette question de la mixité
nous sommes dit qu'elles sont quel
moment de convivialité pour l incarner
leurs bas donc on a mis en place une
cantine une fois par semaine cinquante
personnes valait déjeuner dans les
algeco la formule s'éroder ça
fonctionnait plutôt bien et les élus
étaient attablés avec les personnes sans
abri pour ce qui était des tables on
avait des planches et les tréteaux pour
ce qui était des chaises on avait un
soutien de la mairie qui nous amenait
chaque semaine cinquante chaises
jusque là tout va bien cette cantine ça
nous a permis de tester la mala de
tester la mixité mais ça nous a permis
également de tester la modularité des
espaces comment cet espace pouvait
accueillir plusieurs activités
une activité assez différentes là il
faut que je vous explique un tout petit
peu dans le détail comment se passe l
arrivée de ces douze personnes le soir
elle arrivait pour pouvoir prendre un
repas chaud dormir à l'abri et avoir une
douche dans la salle commune douze
planches vissé sur quatre assauts
étaient posés à même le sol et c'était
là l'endroit où ces douze personnes
dormaient j'ai été particulièrement
choquée de les voir quasiment à même le
sol
mais le directeur du site ne voulait
rien entendre
sur cette question il me rétorque à des
problèmes d'hygiène de pipi au lit de
plus de lits et surtout l'argument le
plus inaudible à mes yeux c'était qu'il
ne fallait pas leur offrir trop de
confort pour continuer de les motiver à
se tourner vers des structures plus
adaptées qui saurait les aider à se
réinsérer
c'est à mes yeux inconcevable mais j'ai
bien compris que frontalement je ne
pouvais rien y faire
j'ai donc ont signé ça dans un coin de
ma tête et j'ai continué s'ils étaient
parqués au goûter sur la question des
lits il était attentif au bon
déroulement des nuits ils trouvent ils
voulaient trouver une solution aux vols
répétés qui avait lieu chaque mi temps
et dans l'espace entre eux le sujet
était important et il avait trouvé le
budget nécessaire pour la réalisation de
casier il m'a demandé de réaliser ces
casiers avant tout des saints je suis
rentré avec lui dans le scénario d'
usage ou ce serait où sera situé ses
casiers qui pourraient y aller
à quel moment commence et sécuriser les
affaires avec un cadenas un cadenas à
code incana à cléo cas très bien mais
qui a la clé est ce que c'est le
surveillant le surveillant il
passé sa soirée en fait c'est sûr or
c'est pas juste un surveillance et un
éducateur spécialisé
donc c'est quand même une bien triste
manière d'occuper cette compétence
j'étais donc pas très convaincus par
notre solution et les usages m'attends
pas réglé j'ai laissé traîner le dessin
des casiers et puis j'ai continué avec
ses chantiers d'amélioration du lieu dit
la réponse est là la solution est
arrivée par un biais je n'attendais pas
j'ai reçu un coup de fil de la mairie
qui m'a expliqué qu'elle était bien
désolé mais que la mairie était là pour
équiper des pour pouvoir équiper des
lieux de manière événementielle mais pas
au quotidien
or là ça faisait des semaines qu'il
venait chaque fois avec les cinquante
chaises donc pour la semaine prochaine
je n'aurais pas cinquante chaises
j'avais donc d'un côté d aider une envie
de pouvoir continuer dans cette grande
cantine mais je n'avais pas d'assise et
de l'autre côté
j'avais des personnes qui dormaient à
même le sol et j'avais de l'argent pour
mettre de côté pour protéger leurs sacs
alors la banque où on a justement
croiser ces deux de ses deux faisceaux
de contraintes et on a trouvé une
solution
on a créé des lib enquête le dessin de
célibat enquête a été fait de telle
manière qu un homme allongé sur le sur
la banquette permettait pour la cantine
d'avoir huit personnes adossé dos à dos
la hauteur de l'a 6 permettait de
pouvoir ranger les affaires sous le sous
le sous le corps est ainsi une fois
allongé la question du vol et des clés
étaient réglés le budget de l'un a servi
à l'autre c'est c'est une de mes plus
belles victoires sur ce projet
mais la plus belle victoire je le clou
du cloud vraiment je ne l'avais pas
prévu pour réaliser ses banquettes j'ai
monté un chantier et pour piloter ce
chantier je me suis appuyé sur yarek un
type qui venait à chaque soir dormir à
l'accueil de nuit un type doux à la rue
le genre de mec qui la ramène pas mais
qui a assuré le fait de vivre avec lui
au clic au quotidien et la confiance que
nous avions tissé lui à moi m'a permis
de déléguer le chantier il a tout gérer
l'approvisionnement les bénévoles
l'outillage je me suis appuyé
entièrement sur lui et notre confiance
et ce cadre de projets lui a permis de
révéler toutes ses compétences aux yeux
de l'équipe de l'association
l'association a pu voir que qu'il
pouvait justement vrai pour ces travaux
et depuis ils ont embauché
c'est le monsieur bricolage de
l'association et c'est lui qui a réparé
tous les logements de l'association
forcément ça à démêler tout ça situation
et depuis il a un logement un salaire et
des papiers quatre ans après mon départ
il faut que je vous confesse que ce
projet n'est toujours pas sorti de terre
mais j'ai appris une chose c'est que on
ne mesure la pertinence d'une idée qu
effet qu'elle produit et que la force
des architectures selon moi et et que
c'est un prétexte puissants et que si on
s'en saisit collectivement on peut faire
réveiller des envies et révéler des
personnes
merci à ceux et celles qui m'inspire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]